[Music]
hey chef whatever here and cheers
i'd like to have a little sip of that
delicious o'leary chardonnay shameless
promotion before we start cooking i want
to cook up a little advice
if you're in your 20s
i'm going to give you five pieces of
advice that i think is going to save
your honey i don't care what you're
thinking listen to this stuff i've been
there i've done that i'm going to help
you out here okay five things you don't
want to do
when you're in your 20s i want to talk
about taking care of your skin and your
face
and that's why i'm really excited to
have tiege handling yeah these guys as a
sponsor
of today's video
they make skin care products for men
they've helped me start and maintain my
skincare routine
by making the entire process really
uncomplicated and easy
easy
honestly it's the best skin care system
for guys
why because it's really easy to use i
recommend you start with their level 1
system basic it comes in a box all the
basics are in here
a daily face wash to get rid of the dirt
and grime on your skin that's important
and i use it every day i care about that
a lot
a two times a week exfoliating scrub to
get rid of dead skin cells yeah
an am moisturizer with spf 20 because
you should always be protecting your
skin from the sun
and the pm moisturizer to help your skin
stay hydrated and healthy throughout the
night when do you think this sounds
corny it's not how do you think mr
wonderful looks so fantastic and chef
wonderful at the same time i care about
my skin my favorite part about teach
handling is that every box comes with an
instruction card that tells you when to
use each product makes it really simple
how much to use and in what order they
really make the process of achieving and
maintaining
your skin amazingly easy
i've been using their products for quite
a while now i kind of hope to admit it
hey i put this stuff on every day
it might sound weird
but i look forward to my morning and
evening routines because i feel amazing
and a lot more confident
after using their
products check out the results
yeah
the teach handling people get tons of
benefits including 25
of the retail price off the ability to
customize your box and you can pause or
cancel anytime and you get free us
shipping if you're out there outside the
united states they offer a low-cost
shipping to almost most countries
and because these handling is sponsoring
today's video they're offering my
viewers a great deal
just click the first link in the
description and not only will you get
teach handling for the best possible
price
but they'll also give you a free gift
with your first box click that link and
get started for just 25
now number two
you gotta stand again it's the hardest
thing to do
every credit card company is coming
after you the minute you turn a team
they want your life and they want you to
carry a balance they can charge 15 16 17
18 19 20 21 percent on how do i know
that because i invest in those credit
card companies because you guys keep
doing that to yourself and i'm making 21
that's crazy
don't let me make that kind of interest
by simply being really constructive of
what you do with credit cards yeah yeah
you need one to start building up your
credit balance i get that but you got to
pay it off every month that's how you
get a really high credit score so start
by just spending 25 30 40 50 bucks or
whatever it is you pay it off every
month and then bingo all of a sudden
your credit score is going through the
roof
but the biggest mistake you make is
spending more than you take in and then
all of a sudden say oh well i won't pay
off the full balance this month and
that's
going to cut you
like a knife
because nobody can make 21 interest you
can't do that in the bond market it's
really hard to make that in stock market
but you're going to pay that if you get
into debt and you do not want that to
happen this is something you really got
to think about
but i want to hire somebody one of these
days or any of these days i go and i
look at their resume and i just maybe
look at their account wherever they put
it on linkedin or wherever else and i
learn a little bit about that person and
i'm talking about all my operating
companies but i do something else i want
you to know
i go to the web and i dig deep into
social media
i want to see the kind of stuff you've
posted
now once you post it it's there forever
so if you're hanging off a balcony in
fort lauderdale out of your mind
swinging from the fences i'm going to
see that i don't like that lots of
employers don't like that they want to
see people i get it you're going to have
fun but you've got to think what you
post
you really got to put a filter on the
future
remembering that i am going to see it
and so is every other employee so when i
find crazy stuff
that makes me pause be responsible in
your post and be creative and you're
supposed to be expressive in your
posting
tell us who you are as you post but
remember there's a future and you want
to be part of it
who knows what you're going to want to
do in 10 years don't let some crazy post
haunt you
so keep it clean
and be thoughtful
you're building your own brand build
your brand every day on social don't
destroy it
very important style how you dress
is who you are
you're communicating to people before
you even say a single word
they're walking in a room nobody knows
who you are
they look at you they see how you're
dressed you can dress any way you want
but you're definitely communicating
brand when you do that so i'm very into
what i wear
check this out you know you see that
those are pajama pants vietnamese pants
that's how i cook i'm proud to wear them
very very comfortable
fantastic
you know very package friendly lots of
air when you're working with a really
hot kitchen like i do all the time i
wear flip-flops i'm cool with it it's a
look it's a style look at this little
you know i love red bands on my watches
i'm marrying it up very cool
all i'm saying is i try to express who i
am and how i wear clothes you know go
shopping for stuff you like but don't
over spend you don't need too much stuff
you need good quality stuff
make it part of who you are now you're
in your 20s you're thinking about
dropping out of college another piece of
advice don't do it
finish what you started now hopefully
you've chosen something that you like i
used to say the only thing to go to
college for was engineering but i have
changed my mind about that the arts
matter now why
because the power of digitization all
around the world people want to tell
stories direct to consumer now and even
giant companies are hiring the very best
film editors storytellers
videographers animators anybody that can
take a story make it digital and
communicate it successfully on all the
social media platforms so if you're
really good at linkedin if you're really
good at twitter or instagram or facebook
or any other platform
they want you you're a tick-tocker they
want you the whole idea is this is the
new commerce of america and it's because
the pandemic but all of a sudden
the starving artists aren't starving
anymore so now i'm saying look
engineering still works but if you're in
the arts that's cool too because last
year in terms of all my operating
companies
including my food businesses chef
wonderful as you know our largest most
expensive growth area
was digital media and the people that
make it
those are the five things you don't want
to do in your 20s until next time my
friends
center
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe